death
that terrible and inevitable consequence
of life but as the foundation discovered
in the aftermath of project amarong its
absence can be even more horrifying than
its presence let's bring you up to speed
shall we here's the story so far after
the death of overseer 05-11
the scp foundation's infamous 05 council
learned the horrifying truth of what
happens to human beings after death
there is no afterlife no everlasting
paradise or eternal damnation instead
the dead are cursed to remain conscious
aware of everything happening to them
after passing even their bodies
decomposing to combat this a member of
the council 05-4 established project
amarong this was an internal
foundation-backed endeavor created with
one singular goal in mind to capture and
contain death itself as part of this
project researchers created the machine
known as scp-3448
at first it seemed like just an ordinary
mri machine from a hospital
scp-3448 had a number of anomalous
modifications made to it giving it a
rather unique function the device was
capable of separating someone's
consciousness from their body putting
them in a sort of half-dead state while
in this state a subject placed within
the machine referred to as scp-3448-a
could maintain a consistent line of
two-way communication between their
disembodied consciousness and the
foundation instead of deploying a member
of d-class personnel one of the scp
foundation's own agents was placed into
scp-3448
agent anthony michaels was elected to
act as scp-3448-a
and serve as the conduit between the
living world and the endless nothing
that lies beyond but as often happens
when people dabble with forces they
cannot possibly understand something
went awry
project amarong's mission to contain
death took an unexpected turn when agent
michaels was placed into the machine
things ended up getting much much worse
buckle up because we're about to dive
into the ill-fated outcome of the
death-defying project demeron the
catalyst for the end of death itself one
of the components connected to
scp-3448 is a monitor this screen is
used to interpret the electrical
activity of
scp-3448-a's brain once they have
entered the half-death state known as
scp-3448-1
this component of the anomalous mri
machine is able to intake these
electrical signals and interpret them as
images occasionally with words
accompanying them too during his time in
the machine agent michael's brainwaves
were able to deliver some rather
interesting imagery to the foundation
researchers a number of these seem to be
a bizarre and seemingly disconnected
series of images almost like something
taken directly out of a dream hard to
find any real context for the first was
a human figure surrounded by a swarm of
buzzing insects after 43 minutes the
monitor connected to
scp-3448 showed this figure looking
swollen as if it had been stung by the
insects which flew away as the obscured
humanoid collapsed the next day the
screen showed a man lying alone in the
desert somewhere with an oasis in the
distance almost like the classic mirage
someone dying of thirsties just out of
reach as they stumble through the
endless sand dunes the same day the
image changed to a man in a fetal
position in a room made of dirt with
bones and roots protruding from the
walls
so far the dreamlike images coming
through from agent michael's half-dead
mind looks strange almost like the
contents of the infamous videotape in
the horror movie the ring did any of
these images mean anything and if so
what was the man the human shaped figure
appearing in them agent michaels himself
or some kind of representation of his
disembodied consciousness now that it
had been separated from him by the
scp-34
machine one of the foundation's
researchers described the imagery seen
on the monitor as being akin to watching
someone's acid trip for over a week
however the same researcher also
theorized that because agent michaels
was being held in a half-dead state that
the other things appearing in the images
with him could also be similarly
half-dead the researcher believed that
what they were seeing was more of an
abstract conceptual representation of
death not a conventional afterlife like
the idea of walking up to the pearly
gates or the fire and brimstone of hell
so the researcher decided to try
half-killing objects partially
disassembling things and placing them
into
scp-3448 with agent michaels sure enough
doing this meant that the man in the
images now had whatever object was put
into the machine for example when they
broke apart a lighter it appeared in the
man's possession on screen unfortunately
this was the biggest mistake that the
researcher could have made the images on
the monitor began to show the man now
believed to be agent anthony michaels
being attacked by a little girl thought
to be a manifestation of the very
concept of death this girl was seen
stabbing the agent with a femur
torturing him while the foundation were
sat watching powerless and unable to
help the researcher requisitioned a
handgun partially disassembling it like
the lighter in order to arm agent
michaels against his attacker and it
worked but the consequences were
unfathomable sure enough michaels was
able to draw the firearm and fend off
his attacker the agent fired off a shot
that over the course of more bizarre
creepy and disjointed images involving
skeletons and teddy bears seemed to hit
the girl square in the head the image
that followed showed agent michael
standing alone in the garden flowers
blooming as dead insects rained down
around him on the ground beside the
agent was a stuffed animal a crow with a
bullet hole through its head shortly
after the following words appeared on
the monitor attached to scp-3448
i hope you enjoy your hike dad for a few
short moments nothing seemed to be all
that different to the foundation in the
outside world the researcher who had
provided agent michaels with the handgun
was trapped in a state of shock for a
brief while until five minutes later
when the phone calls started flooding in
the first came from joyce a woman known
to the researcher who frantically
explained how her father who had been
dying now was totally fine all of a
sudden the researcher couldn't quite
tell if she was happy or terrified by
what seemed to be happening next came
the orders from above the overseer 05-4
the only council member aware of project
amarong and who had backed it
financially called to congratulate the
researcher and the rest of the team
behind the project it seemed that
damarang had been successful in the goal
they had set out with to contain the
cognito hazard known as death 05-4
demanded that all records and
information regarding the project was to
be incinerated covered up from the rest
of the foundation's knowledge but the
truth was far far worse than any at the
foundation realized it soon dawned on
the researcher who had been documenting
agent michael's time in
scp-3448 that project damarang had not
succeeded at all they hadn't contained
anything hadn't secured the conceptual
form of death what they had done instead
by foolish mistake was neutralize death
they had killed death itself and now the
world as they knew it was gone changed
almost indefinitely now not a single
person in the world could die
they had caused the end of death on the
surface a world without death sounds
like a utopia a blissful society where
everyone on earth lives a long and
prosperous life but those with a little
more foresight will know that peaceful
immortality for the human race is a
fool's dream think about how many people
there are living in the world right now
the overall global population grows
exponentially every year while death
might be a sad and somber part of life
it is unfortunately necessary even with
all the deaths that occur worldwide
every year the resources of planet earth
are still being stretched thin water oil
food electricity homes everywhere you go
there are plenty of people who don't
have enough of any so what happens when
people don't die just keep aging
infinitely what happens when the earth
becomes too overcrowded when the number
of people overshadows the number of
resources even more than it already does
society as we know it across the globe
would collapse and that's exactly what
happened the foundation had done the
unthinkable they had vanquished the very
concept that takes us from being alive
to being deceased but there's a reason
kilroy j oldster called death the great
equalizer of human beings it is meant to
catch up with everyone every person born
is ultimately destined to die and by
removing that element of human mortality
from the equation the scp foundation had
unknowingly pushed the world towards
disaster with the actions of agent
michaels within scp-3448
death as a concept ceased to exist
almost instantaneously as if someone had
flipped an off switch people didn't
become undead things that had long since
passed away and been confined to six
feet under the dirt didn't start clawing
their way back up to the surface we
aren't talking about a zombie outbreak
this isn't dawn of the dead instead
human beings across the world just
refuse to die their brains continuing to
function and bodies continuing to age
despite any damage or injuries they
sustained fatal wounds were now just as
dangerous as getting a broken ankle or
sprained wrist the concerns about how
undying humans were overpopulating the
planet were also extended to animals too
which were also affected by the end of
death that project demeron had triggered
as a result the threat of starvation on
a potentially global scale was greater
than such a concern ever had been of
course the scp foundation left the
concerns of a potential humanitarian
crisis to those in charge of world
governments the united nations could
worry themselves over how to feed and
care for a population that simply won't
die the foundation had bigger fish to
fry their mistake had caused this
situation so only they could undo it the
only solution they could come up with
figuring out new ways of killing people
the foundation wanted to bring death
back to the dead their experiments began
with the use of d-class personnel
commanding them to attempt to kill one
another through various means
strangulation both by hand or with the
use of a belt didn't seem to work the
way it should have with the d-class
being strangled likely going into a coma
due to a lack of oxygen to their brain
not dying but living in unconscious
agony in a similar experiment placing a
d-class in a vacuum led to burst blood
vessels impaired motor functions
widespread paralysis to name a few forms
of damage but still death could not be
achieved cutting blood loss poisoning
starvation shooting even decapitation of
multiple d-class personnel all yielded
the same result in some sense simply
allowing these subjects to die might
have just been kinder if death was still
possible that is the foundation even
went as far as removing the brain of a
live monkey placing it in a blender and
testing to see if there was any
electrical activity present and wouldn't
you know it was somehow still alive at
least as far as life can be measured by
human beings this key part of our
existence the underlying fact of death
itself was no more removing that was
like taking a crucial element out of a
circuit the world just didn't function
in the way it was supposed to anymore
what hope did the foundation have now
what could possibly be done to solve
this colossal mistake well the answer is
very little apart from waiting for the
inevitable collapse of society what
awaited was a world in ruin where
everyone was starving but nobody could
die
a planet and a people just hanging on
until the universe eventually blinked
out of existence so that maybe then they
could rest in peace the moral of this
story you can't cheat death because
death isn't the other player it's the
game
itself now go check out secret group
that runs the world scp-05 council
explained and
scp-006 fountain of youth for more
videos about attempts to cheat death and
its not so pleasant consequences